you can view this diagram as an org
chart of the government of the United
States and what we have highlighted in
this blue green color that is the
executive branch and the things that
fall under the executive branch and you
can't even see everything a lot of it
falls off of the screen and when you see
something like this with roughly 2.6
million people part of that executive
branch part of the government's
bureaucracy and with the president at
the top of the executive branch you
might get the idea that the president is
quite powerful and you would be correct
the president is a powerful role but
there's some factors about how the
executive branch is structured and its
size that might keep the president from
being quite as powerful as you might
first believe first of all managing 2.6
million people is no easy task
ask anyone who even has to manage an
organization of 20 or 30 people much
less 2,000 people or two hundred
thousand people it can get quite
difficult you have to manage through
many layers of Management the other
interesting thing that makes the
president's role in the executive branch
different than say the CEO of a
corporation is that yes the president
can make many appointments in fact the
president can make several thousand
appointments and most of those
appointments sit atop the various
departments but most of the bureaucracy
the federal bureaucracy most of this 2.6
million they are not appointed by the
president those are professionals in
their field they are part of the civil
service system so as they make various
judgments and interpret laws in certain
ways and execute the machinery of the
bureaucracy they might not be completely
in lockstep with the goals of the
president the goals that the president
has for their administration relate to
that the senior appointments especially
the cabinet secretaries those serve at
the pleasure of the president if the
president becomes unhappy with them if
the president finds that they're
disloyal in some way the president can
choose to have them leave essentially
fire them although in the news you'll
sometimes see is the president accepts
their resignation but as you get further
down the bureaucracy the president does
not have that control the Supreme Court
has ruled
that for officers the president could
can fire them but as you go down into
the regular rank-and-file the majority
of this 2.6 million people the president
can't fire them without cause the
president can't fire them just because
they don't like those employees or they
feel that those employees don't
completely agree with the president it
has to be for just cause and this is why
you'll see that some parts of the
executive branch say from the Department
of Justice they might have
investigations into things that the
President does not want them to
investigate into oftentimes they will
investigate the president this happened
during the Nixon administration part of
the Watergate investigations this
happened under the Clinton
administration this is happening at the
time of this video as part of the Trump
administration the Mueller investigation
and the president can't just willy-nilly
fire folks if they say hey why are you
looking into my matters because of this
principle so they can't fire just anyone
within the executive branch
now what levers does the president have
to maybe exert more control than the
things that I have just described well
of course I've mentioned the
appointments that the president can make
and this could number in the several
thousands of appointments I've seen
estimates as high as 4,000 appointments
that the president needs to can make
they can fire the president can fire
officers so these would be the senior
political appointments things like the
cabinet secretaries of people at the
head of these various departments but
even that could have some significant
political consequences the president
could try to shift responsibilities from
one part of the bureaucracy to another
or shift budget from one part of the
bureaucracy to another but this is also
not so easy because once again it's a
large and complex bureaucracy the
president would have to do it through
many layers of Management and at the end
of the day things like budget which
Department gets how much money this is
at the end of the day something that the
Congress will decide is once again part
of the separation of powers
we've talked about in multiple videos
another thing that the president can try
to do and we've talked about this in
other videos are the idea of executive
orders executive orders oftentimes can
be a president trying to clarify how a
law should be interpreted how it should
be executed upon by the bureaucracy if
the president feels that its bureaucracy
is not interpreting laws in the way that
meets the president's goals so I will
leave you there the president clearly
the most powerful office in the United
States on top of a 2.6 million person
bureaucracy that's part of the executive
branch but the president is not a king
the president is not a chief executive
officer of a for-profit company where
they can have a lot more control they're
limited by just the inertia of the
bureaucracy they're limited by their
ability to hire and fire people they're
limited by the complexity of the
bureaucracy but they do have some tools
at their disposal where they can try to
shape the direction and the goals of
these 2.6 million federal employees